on a repéré sur l'élu rouge
à quelques minutes de l'ouverture de ce
bureau de vote les dernières consignes
sont données les assesseurs sont prêts
pour une journée bien faire notre devoir
les électeurs veiller au bon déroulement
des bureaux de vote
8h à l'ouverture il y à déjà du monde
chacun sa raison pour voter de bonheur
j'ai une journée de randonnée et donc je
vais le plus tôt possible pour eux
avaient voté tout simplement geôles des
mollahs c'est du bonheur chez les
voleurs matinaux pas ses premiers
électeurs sont convaincus de la
nécessité de voter deux fois sa
sélection qui nous touchent de près quoi
donc vous pensez
c'est un canton akwa le dis on a tous le
droit de vote donc autant en profiter
c'est le seul jour où notre voie elle
compte autant que la voix de tout le
monde une aubaine particularité assez
rare en france les neuf bureaux de vote
de la ville seront regroupées ici dans
leur seul et unique lui direction de
l'ars surcouche à 13 km à 15 heures 540
votants se sont déplacés sur les 1002
181 inscrits
malgré un beau soleil ses électeurs
n'ont pas oublié l'importance du vote
je vais voter parce que c'est un devoir
mais bon c'est vrai que la politique
aujourd'hui
y'a pas très gai pas trop battre et j'ai
envie de soutenir mes idées même si
c'est pas celle de tout le monde c'est
pas grave il faut on n'a pas démocratie
personnes arrêtées moi ce sont les
élections les plus importantes et c'est
pour ça aujourd'hui j'ai un devoir de me
présenter ici notamment dans une
circonscription j'ai grandi et d'autres
ont préféré passer leur tour
c'était plus cet imprimé d'une activité
sportive pour moi donc c'était ma
dernière des préoccupations à dire t'es
même pas au courant pour y rester
aujourd'hui gweth
avis aux étourdis
dans une semaine il faudra de nouveau se
rendre dans l'isoloir